we're going to talk about magic squares
of squares so first thing we're going to
do is uh talk about what a magic square
is we're going to start with a three by
three grid we're going to have eight not
one and a six and a three and a five
seven and a four and a nine and a two so
this is a three by three array of
numbers and what's incredible here is
that if you add the numbers down the
columns so like eight plus three plus
four you're gonna get fifteen you're
gonna get 15 no matter what column you
add down or if you look at the rows and
if you add those up then you also get 15
so all the rows add up to 15 and also
the two diagonals so the principal
diagonal
so this is five plus two is seven plus
eight is fifteen and then if you look at
the other diagonal so 4 plus 6 is 10
plus 5 is 15. so everything adds up to
15. so columns rows and the two
diagonals add up to 15. that's a perfect
pure magic square in fact this is the
earliest or you know up to some sort of
rearrangement of the of the numbers it's
uh it's the earliest known uh recorded
magic square it's usually called the the
low shoe there's records of it from
about 2200 BC the Chinese tradition has
it that the emperor you uh saw this
magic square on the back of a turtle
it's a sort of beautiful story I know
there are lots of other magic squares
we're going to talk about them shortly
yeah is a magic square still a magic
square if any number is repeated or is
that kind of imperfect I so I would
argue that those are imperfect magic
squares and and in fact that's that's
kind of what makes it hard I think to to
find magic squares if you allow
repetitions you know you you can really
find magic Source quite easily right I
could just repeat all the numbers here
right just take your favorite number
minus 19. I think it would be nine but
nine is now Prime so it's 19. so if I
put 19 everywhere in these nine entries
I'll just get a magic square that way
but it feels like it's not
it's not a real magic square it feels
like a fake magic square so what I want
to do is look at three by three magic
squares but I want to impose one more
condition which is that I want the
entries themselves to be the squares of
numbers so I'm going to draw for you an
example of this and it'll be a bit of a
cheat people who've been seeing number
file videos for a while are going to
recognize this so this is 29 squared 1
squared 47 squared 41 squared 37 squared
1 squared 23 squared 41 squared and 29
and this is a very famous
magic square and it was made famous by
number five so this is the the Parker
Square so I'm not calling it The Parker
Square you know what this video is I'm
caught it on for crying out loud this
was famously Matt's attempt at all
squares that's right that's right it's a
very good attempt I think this this is a
very reasonable uh attempt in fact it it
complies with almost all the
requirements of of a of a magic square
of squares right so every single entry
is a square number
right uh and it's it's true that if you
add up all the rows and all the columns
and if you add up the two diagonals it
all adds up to the same number so it
satisfies the main requirements for
being a magic square doesn't does wasn't
one of the diagonals fail wait sorry can
we check that this diagonal here works
this diagonal here doesn't work one of
the diagonals does not and so in in that
sense it's not quite a magic square of
squares it's what people tend to call a
semi-magic square
um and there's some repetitions of the
entries so for example you see the two
ones here you see a couple of 29s a
couple of 41s and so it sort of feels
like it's it's cheating just a little
bit but it's a really good attempt okay
so so you know it's it's a good starting
point you know when you sometimes in
math when you can't solve a really
difficult problem you try to solve a
simpler problem you know and and making
some of these allowing some of these
entries to be uh the same as a way of
trying to simplify the problem that and
in a way that might some interesting
mathematics as well okay Parker Square
great good attempt yes okay so there are
there are a couple of other uh squares
that I want to show you because so so as
we saw in the Parker Square there's just
a couple of things that aren't quite
right and there are some really famous
ones these are sort of from the late 90s
so one of them is called the Bremner
Square okay this is a big one okay so
this is another attempt at a magic
square of squares and it's it's very
good in sort of a different way from the
Parker Square this time you'll notice
almost immediately that there's two
entries that are not squares that's
where this fails that feels like an even
more fundamental failure to me yes are
they close to being squares ah I not
really I don't think it is a little bit
sad that they're not they're not really
squares but you know what does what is
true here though is that the columns and
the rows and both diagonals are up to
the same thing so somehow we managed to
at least preserve that property but then
we broke the squares we do have distinct
entries so
you know you're sort of you feel like
you're making progress I mean it'd be
you know cool to have one that had like
eight squares you know and maybe only
one that's not a square
um I don't know of one and I'm not sure
if one has been found yet there's
another Square consisting of square
entries which is almost the magic square
it's the same magic square it's by Salos
and in a sense it's sort of a an
improvement on the Parker Square in that
all the entries are distinct however
just like with the Parker Square One of
the diagonals doesn't add up to the same
number that all the others I'd up to
that feels like one of the best attempts
so far doesn't it like that's right yes
in fact it's it's really nice that if
you just remove one of the conditions
then you really can find them it's it's
a it's a very difficult problem
precisely because of how all of the
conditions come together of course this
is a fundamental question here does one
exist has anyone ever found a magic
square of squares as far as I know no
it's it's really sad and in fact
what I want to do today is try to
convince you that there probably isn't
one okay so I know that's sort of a sad
thing to say uh I would love it for it
to be a magic square of squares
um but but I think sort of of geometry
is giving us a bunch of indications that
this just might not be the case and so
in fact what geometry suggests is that
if there is a magic square of squares
it's going to be really really difficult
to find and it sort of be beyond what we
can do by just sort of like trying small
things this doesn't look like geometry
to me right right oh my God yes thank
you for that question yeah let me try to
show you where the geometry at least
starts coming up let's do it so we're
trying to find nine numbers each of them
a square and so I need to give them
names I'll call them X1 squared and X2
squared and X3
squared and so on
what we're hoping for is nine distinct
positive integers X1 through X9
um that I can put into uh one of these
three by three grids in such a way that
the the rows the columns and the two
diagonals add up to the same number and
so I can actually write out what those
conditions are in terms of just algebra
right like a jig monster equation like
yeah it's going to be a set of monster
equations in fact so let me show you so
for example I need to know that the
first row is equal to the sum of the
elements of the first row is equal to
the sum of the elements in the second
row so I can just write out this monster
equation okay I also need the same two
sums to equal the sum of the third row
so I can write another equal sign here
this all has to be the same okay I also
need to know that this sum is the same
as the sum of the two diagonals so let
me those next so there's X1 squared plus
x 5 squared plus X nine squared and then
the other diagonal so it'll be X3
squared plus X5 squared plus X seven
squared this is a bit messy but we still
have to do the columns so the First
Column will be X1 Square plus X4 squared
plus x 7 squared okay and then I'll do
the second column X2 squared plus X5
squared plus X8 squared okay and I'm
still missing the third column okay but
here's something this is a really
important observation so once I know
that all three rows add up to the same
number and the first two columns add up
to the same number that forces the last
column to add up to the same number as
as all the previous uh rows and columns
and so this last thing is not a
condition that we need to sort of set
out because it's already implied by all
the other ones that we have imposed so
this is sort of an important thing
because it cuts down on the number of
equal signs that I've written okay so
there's only one two three four five six
equal signs I don't need one more equal
sign to say that this is all equal to
the sum of the last column that's an
important geometric Point okay so we
have a mess here so we have this like
huge system of equations okay and so I
need to make sort of a few observations
about the system of equations what I
want to try to you soon is that it's
going to be really difficult to try to
solve this particular system of
equations with the extra requirements
that all these X's are different and
this is really sort of the important the
important bit I feel like you don't have
to make that argument to me it already
looks difficult but all right okay
sounds good yes we have nine variables
and we have these six equations and so I
wanna I wanna think of these nine
variables as like a point in some kind
of space and this space has to have room
for this many coordinates okay so I want
this to be a point it's it looks like
this is going to be a point in some kind
of nine-dimensional space you know like
usually we have like a three-dimensional
space that has like X Y and Z
coordinates there's only three
coordinates here I'm going to need a
space where I can write down nine
coordinates
okay so that looks like it could be a
nine-dimensional space but there's
something really special about the
equations that we have that allow me to
cut things down sort of by one dimension
instead of sort of even though I'm going
to write the my points using nine
coordinates they're really sort of only
eight Dimensions that are in the works
in the same way that we talked about uh
you know some squares feel like you know
they might be a little fake there's a
sense in which some squares even though
they appear different they feel like in
our bones they're kind of the same okay
and let me kind of show you that with
something that's probably a little more
familiar which is sort of the
Pythagorean triangles this is a very
famous triangle the 345 triangle and we
have that three squared plus 4 squared
is equal to 5 squared right this is the
Pythagorean relation but you know here's
a it's a different triangle but this is
going to be a 6 8 10 triangle and
there's something funny about this which
is that okay it's still true so 6 Square
squared plus 8 squared is equal to 10
squared but some of these triangles
don't really feel that different it just
feels like it took this triangle and I
just kind of scaled it up in a sense the
you know the triangles literally are
different but they don't feel like a
genuinely different triangle it looks
like it just took the triangle I already
knew and I scaled it up and the same
thing is going to happen with things
like magic squares it doesn't even have
to be magic squares or squares right
there's a little shoe and so I can just
take the low shoe and just multiply
everything by two so I'm going to put a
16 here and a 2 there and a 12 there and
a 6 and a 10 and a 14 and an 8 and then
18 and a four okay and now everything
adds up to 30 this time but that's not
very surprising I I just scaled every
single number by two and so you know the
equations that give you a magic square
you know it's just like multiplying
those equations by two and so this
doesn't really feel like a genuinely
different magic Square from the low shoe
in in a literal sense it is different
but somehow it came from the same mold
and so so that's really the important
thing is that that when we look at all
of these coordinates and I multiply them
by seven when I look at my magic square
of squares each one of these entries
will get multiplied by 49 because 7
squared is 49 and so every single entry
will get multiplied by 49 and then it'll
still be true that the rows and the
columns on the two diagonals will add up
to the same any solution to this problem
and I scale it up or down I could also
just have fractions instead in there
I'll still have a magic square of
squares so these Solutions have this
very nice scaling property and what that
means is that even though you see sort
of nine coordinates you only really have
about eight degrees of freedom so the
reason that's important is that so the
natural habitat for these equations is
something like an eight-dimensional
space
what do I mean by the habitat of an
equation so let me just remind you you
know if I if I just worked
in the usual plane where I had X and Y
coordinates so I had two coordinates I
have two Dimensions you know I can look
at an equation like this x squared plus
Choice squared equals one this is one
equation in this two-dimensional space
and it cuts out for us a circle of
radius One X squared plus y squared
equals one and so what we're doing here
is something similar it's just much
harder to visualize because I'm going to
work in a space that technically has
nine coordinates
but only really eight degrees of freedom
and inside that space I'm going to look
at the solutions of some big set of
polynomials and this set of polynomials
will carve out a geometric shape just
like x squared plus y squared equals one
carves out a geometric shape on the
plane it's just that it's you know it's
hard to visualize eight-dimensional
space so I don't know how to draw that
here but but the object is out there and
it exists so not only is that impossible
to imagine the playing field you also
don't even know what the configuration
of the players are right that's right
yes yes so so we really have to sort of
use use our imagination and the algebra
this is sort of a really important idea
that that we're we're sort of trying to
do some geometry but but when we can't
visualize things sometimes the algebra
is still there and we can work with the
algebra instead of the geometry so we
have this eight dimensional space
um and if you look back at the set of of
equations that we wrote there are six
equal signs and so each one of these
equal times is putting a constraint on
this eight-dimensional space so you
start with this eight dimensional space
and then I put a constraint in it and so
now what I'm holding is probably a seven
dimensional thing and then I put another
constraint in it and so now these two
constraints have to be satisfied
simultaneously and so the intersection
is probably something that's six
dimensional and I keep doing this and if
I have six constraints well okay I'm
just you know right eight minus six is
equal to two once I sort of put all
these constraints together it looks like
what I should have is some kind of
surface some kind of kind of
two-dimensional thing each constraint is
sort of cutting me down in one dimension
I started with eight degrees of freedom
and I've taken away six and so
um even though it's very hard to
actually visualize something like this
it looks like it could be some kind of
surface so there's some two-dimensional
surface that would hold the key to
everything exactly this is exactly the
point there is out there there is this
sort of incredible you know now I'll
just do like a metaphor for it there's
this two-dimensional surface and each
point on that surface is going to have
coordinates X1 X2 all the way to X9 and
this point encodes one of these magic
squares of squares
now what's important has this surface
got a name uh I no can I suggest one
what would you like to call it the
Parker surface
that's awesome
all right okay let's call it the Parker
surface yeah so so any point on the
Parker surface is going to give you a
magic square of squares now this surface
really is there I think one of the the
things we have to realize is that that
these X's could also be like not just
integers right we are looking for
integers we want integers but but you
know if I just sort of write out these
equations and I let X1 through X9 you
know be more General numbers mean like
Pi or e or you know some something with
an infinite decimal expansion that's
random
um those are perfectly good numbers too
and so what happens is that this square
is there but almost every time you write
one of these points down on it there's
at least one coordinate that's just not
going to be an integer or a fraction and
so so what we're really trying to do is
you know our job is to try to find a
point on the surface all of whose
coordinates are integers and distinct
okay and this is this is where things
get tricky because inside this space
right you can actually take something
that looks kind of like a plank and then
it'll sort of cut the surface and this
will be for example the locus where like
maybe two of the coordinates are the
same that could definitely happen and
you know things like the Parker Square
you know have the property that some of
of the entries are the same and so for
example it can be a point that happens
to lie there and this is the tragedy
that we seem to face is that on this
surface every time we have a point that
seems to give us a magic square of
squares these points tend to lie on
these very special curves of the surface
uh where you have conditions like you
know X1 is equal to X2 or X3 is equal to
minus X7 or something like this because
when you first told me about the surface
I thought maybe there'd be no points on
the surface where all all of them are
integers but there are some there so
that's exactly right and and this you
you hit on something really important
Brady which is that this is what makes
this problem really difficult is that
that this surface really has points with
integer coordinates it's just that we
don't like the points that we see
there's also the one where you've set
everything equal just put everything
equal to one that's a perfectly good
point on the surface 3 is equal to 3 is
equal to three is equal to three is
equal to three that'll work this surface
is obviously of infinite size oh yeah
yeah yeah there's there's lots and lots
of points on on the surface so when this
is what makes it hard so so in in
there's this area of math called
diophantine geometry that that tries to
exactly solve this kind of problem where
you take a collection of polynomial
equations like the ones that Define the
magic square of squares and and they try
to find integer Solutions uh or prove
that there are no integer Solutions
other than sort of you know a few
obvious ones that we see but that we're
not really interested in the same thing
happens with formosa's theorem which is
really aggravating you know for Mazda's
theorem has Solutions right you know
zero to the N plus 1 to the n
equals 1 to the N so the format equation
has Solutions what makes it really
difficult is to show that there are no
Solutions other than you know the
solutions that contain at least one zero
okay and that's uh that that's a much
more difficult problem in math we have
all these you know a whole slew of
techniques for showing that systems of
equations have no integer Solutions
whatsoever
but that's not the case here there are
integer Solutions so what we're trying
to do is to show that there aren't
Solutions other than the ones that we
actually see and that's a much more
difficult problem to solve you told me
earlier that you've come to the
conclusion that it's really unlikely
that one of these exists what you have
shown me so far has made me more hopeful
that one exists yes I understand so so
why why do I think that one might not
exist okay yeah I I guess I did yeah
take away my hope
[Applause]
okay so I'm gonna try to explain why I
think that even though we have this huge
surface worth of points all of which
actually give you a magic square of
squares there's just no point where all
of the entries are integers and they're
distinct why do these points even exist
in the first place and and so this is a
philosophical point but it's you know
points that satisfy polynomial equations
that that are you know all integers are
very very rare they're sort of almost
accidents of Nature and and this is sort
of something really important to bear in
mind so we know if instead of a surface
if we had a curve curves come in sort of
three flavors from that this sort of
integer arithmetic point of view the
first one is called rational and in fact
the circle that we were looking at
before this is kind of a perfect example
of a rational curve what makes these
curves themselves have lots and lots of
points that have either rational or
integer coordinates you know here's
here's already a point in on the surface
zero one if I sort of take the line that
connects that point to some number t on
the real number line then I can do a
little bit of analytic geometry and
compute this thing you'll see that it's
2T squared divided by t squared plus one
and then t squared minus 1 over t
squared plus 1. this actually has to do
with Pythagorean triples but that's a
story for a different a what's important
here you see is that if T is like an
integer or some rational number then
these expressions are also going to be
integers or fractions more generally
there's heaps of rational numbers on the
real line and so I just picked some
rational number T and I do this
construction and it gives me a point on
my curve that has a rational coordinate
so rational curves have this like
incredible property that the moment you
have one point okay I need I need one
point to get started then I can use that
one point to construct lots and lots and
lots of other points then there's
elliptic curves so elliptic curves sort
of have this funny kind of shape usually
they're defined by qubit polynomials
elliptic curves have this incredible
thing that you can add points on them
okay so if I take p and Q okay this is
not P plus q but if I just sort of
reflect it down I can call this P plus q
and this sort of crazy little
construction that I just did happens to
actually sort of satisfy things like
associativity which is something that
you know if I have three things you know
I can move the parentheses around so
elliptic curves have this crazy property
that you can add points on them and the
reason that's important is because it
allows you to also create new points out
of old points so if I have an old point
I can add it to itself for example and
then create a new point and then I can
add that point to itself and create a
new point and so so elliptic curves have
this also this property that that if I
start with a point I can propagate it so
rational curves are great elliptic
curves are great in that you know you
they can come with lots of points and
then there's General type curves and
those those are sort of well they're
sort of more complicated but one thing
that's amazing is that they always have
finitely many points with coordinates
that are rational this this is a
spectacular theorem from the early 80s
maybe 1982 it was proved by fall things
and he he got the field medal for this
theorem so this this was sort of a big a
big deal it was called the mordell
conjecture back then and now it's
balding's theorem what we have is not a
curve okay it is it is a Surface but I'm
telling you this story because it
actually plays a very key role in in our
surface so so when we have curves they
sort of come in three different flavors
two of those flavors have lots and lots
of points and one flavor does not so
what happens with with the surface that
we were calling the the Parker surface
right is that as a consequence of some
work that me and a couple of co-authors
Nels Brown and Jordan Thomas were
working on is we managed to show that on
this surface right here
there are only finitely many curves of
these two types and this is this is
really something that surprised us so
our surface is full of Curves made of
Curves exactly exactly you can you can
take a surface and just like chop it up
into lots of Curves and then you know if
you're looking for points on that give
you a magic square of squares one thing
you might try to do is instead of
looking at the whole surface just look
at a curve inside that surface and maybe
you get lucky and maybe your curve is
one of these two types and then you can
use what we know about these two types
to actually construct magic squares of
squares but the sad thing is that the
surface that parametrizes magic squares
of squares the Parker surface has only
finitely many of these rational or
elliptic curves it doesn't only need one
it only needs one you're right but but
here's the the increasing thing is
it has more than one in fact this uh
this Parker surface has 368 of these
curves that that we know of so there's
at least 368 of these rational or
elliptic curves the sad thing though is
that the way we've constructed these is
that we we looked at slices like this
you know what happens if I take X1 equal
to X2 that gives me some kind of curve
on the surface and then either this
curve or you know the curve itself might
break into a few pieces when I do the
slicing you know those individual curves
are either rational or elliptic but they
have this property the X1 is equal to X2
so so the 368 curves that we can find
they contain points but all of the
points on these curves are are going to
give us these kind of fake magic squares
which is really really sad
um okay and so here's the final kicker
though there is a conjecture
um so so Parker surface so this has
finitely many finitely many rational and
elliptic curves so so our idea to try to
use these curves to produce points uh it
isn't looking so good like I say this is
you know some theorem that came out of
of work that that uh me and a couple of
of co-authors were uh working on and I
mean it was kind of neat I mean we
didn't expect that that we would be able
to prove something about this very
specific surface but now the kicker is
that there's there's something called
the the langvoida conjecture this is the
the incredible thing the surface that we
have here is a particular kind of
surface it's also called the general
type surface and Lang and voida sort of
made a series of very deep conjectures
but when you apply those conjectures to
the surface what it says is that outside
of the rational and the elliptic curves
there can be at most finitely many
points on this on the surface who all of
whose coordinates are integers right
there's tons and tons of points on the
surface but there's only going to be
finitely many points uh out outside of
of the this nice locus of rational
elliptic curves all of whose uh
coordinates are going to be integers
there's finitely many I'll call them
rational points outside the rational and
elliptic curves so where does that leave
us I get the feeling from talking to you
as soon as the search space becomes
finite you become very despondent and
lose hope yes it's finite because of
this sort of General conjecture but
often finite can mean empty as well and
so so it's entirely possible that it's
not not just finite it's just isn't
there there just isn't a set of of
points so somehow the moral of the story
is that
either we need to find some more of
these rational or elliptic curves on the
surface and hope for the best there's
only a finite supply of them so we're
not you know we can't just keep trying
this all the time and and in fact you
know we might actually get a complete
list at some point of all of these and
then you know we really understand
rational you know points on rational
analyptic curves so once we have that
finite list find a list we'll be able to
ascertain whether you know you get one
of these magic squares or squares at
least sort of from that point of view or
the other hope is that well you know we
do this and we find nothing but somehow
there's this miracle and and for some
reason that we just don't understand
there's a couple you know one or of a
few more sporadic points on the surface
all of whose coordinates are integers
but but everything we know about the
geometry of surfaces and the geometry of
Curves is really pointing to the idea
that there just isn't a three by three
magic square of squares in the way that
we would like it with distinct integer
coordinates which is kind of sad
but I want to end on a good note though
so okay I need one more piece of paper
yeah so what I want to show you is
something that's kind of mind-boggling
so we've been asking for magic squares
of squares which were three by three
grids that had this property that the
The Columns the rows and the two
diagonals added up to the same thing and
all the entries were squares okay but
now you can do
we can go For Broke here get a four by
four now you got a four by four now and
this is kind of amazing okay so this is
a 4x4 magic square of squares
this is not
a fake magic square of squares this is
this is the real deal due to Euler
around 1770 thereabouts these magic
sorts of squares have a very long
history if you look here sort of Alder
Rose all the columns and the two
diagonals to the same number 85 15. so
this is kind of crazy you know there's a
four by four
but there isn't a three by three okay
and if you go on the internet
you'll also find a five by five and a
genuine one not a fake one you know like
we and if you dig for you know there's
also a six by six
and so on from the geometry point of
view this is actually not too surprising
in fact
I would actually think it'd be really
cool to show that that if you take an N
by n grid
then and N is at least four then you can
produce one of these magic squares of
squares and so what happened when you
kicked up because I thought if you
applied when you I thought if you
applied that same process you just
showed me right to this you'd have the
same problem you'd come up with a
surface that was really constrained
exactly okay so what happened right so
so let me just sort of explain briefly
that right so if I have like an N by n
grid right that means that I'm going to
have something like what we did before
so this is n entries this way and an
entry is that way okay so if you have an
N by n grid you have n rows you have n
columns and you still only have two
diagonals okay but now
okay how many variables do you have well
there's n times n so there's N squared
variables
so in the three by three case
there were nine variables
in the four by four case there were sort
of 16 entries
so if if you work on an N by n grid
there's going to be N squared variables
okay so what what has happened here is
that
the the space in which we're working in
right the number of coordinates that
we're going to need is growing really
fast
but but the number of conditions that
we're trying to impose on that space is
not growing anywhere near as fast as as
the space itself so the space itself has
Dimension N squared minus one and then I
have 2N plus two things that I need to
set equal to each other so the Parker
surface is no longer
two-dimensional exactly it's no longer
two-dimensional it's like a huge blob
exactly it's like a huge blob right
right we go up one dimension to n equals
uh
four right and now we're in 15
Dimensions we've made roughly eight huts
and so it's like a big blob it's not a
surface anymore yes that's right the
Parker blob and N dimensions and so the
cool thing though is that these sort of
conjectures that we have about points on
these blobs right it's not a surface
anymore it's a much bigger blob and so
things get harder and harder as these
Dimensions go up but but the the the
main point is that the the geometry of
these spaces as the as n grows it
actually becomes more positively curved
which means that it can Harbor tons and
tons of these kinds of rational and
elliptic curves and so so in fact
um for for Blobs of this kind this and
grows we actually suspect there are lots
and lots of points on those blobs and so
it's sort of not too surprising from the
point of view of geometry that you would
find a four by four magic square squares
or a five by five or a six by six you
know in fact it'd be really cool to
prove that you can get an N by n for n
at least four now do you know what would
be Cola it's finding some number out
there n by n Square where there isn't a
solution again oh my God that would be
amazing by some freak yes that's right
and that could happen because you know
in fact these spaces are very singular
and so sort of the the Notions that we
have about what ought to happen may or
may not work in those spaces I mean we
sort of think that probably it's going
to be okay but we don't really know and
and no one has really sort of sat down
to explore these these spaces there's
there's some really interesting
mathematics you know at first it you
know might seem like oh we're just
having some fun with with squares but
there's some really deep geometry that's
that's going on uh behind the scenes and
in fact I I can't really saying this but
but this square that Euler uh came up
with is is
really important in the proof that every
integer is a sum of every natural number
is a sum of four squares there's a very
famous theorem of LaGrange in fact Euler
sent this particular Square to LaGrange
with no explanation about how he had
constructed it you know and then
LaGrange had to kind of work hard and
then you know Euler eventually did
publish the method and then once
LaGrange saw what Euler was doing you
know he was really able to complete his
proof but it's it's amazing to me that
sort of this that might seem just like
pure fun actually ends up having some
some really sort of Deep
and interesting consequences
if you find all the finite curves on
there the rational and elliptic yeah and
they don't throw up what you need
can you prove that there are those
can you prove that there are none of
those other points floating out there is
that provable can you say yeah there
aren't any points as well or are they
always going to be a bit of an unknown I
with with current mathematical
technology I I would not know how to do
that and and I think that that sort of
in general it would be great to have
some kind of mechanism to do exactly
what you just asked you know can and
once I remove the rational elliptic
curves you know can I find this sort of
hypothetical set of finite points packet
points the Parker points if you want yes
now look I know what you're thinking
what does Matt Parker himself think
about all this well Wonder no more we
have a very special Matt Parker reacts
video on number file two there's a link
on the screen and in the video
description